welcome to all his trailer commentaries
not sure what that noise was but I am
sure of today's movie wild wild west
Wicky Wicky wild Wicky Wicky wild this
is the show where we talk about the
honest trailer which is on another
channel and if you stick around to the
end there's some deleted scenes but
first I've got a Wicky Wicky wild wild
announcement this shows going to screen
junkies the screen junkies Channel sorry
sense yes you know like why don't the
shows that are about that show be on the
same channel no one told me how to
message this so I'm just gonna wing it
yeah yeah that's what's happening right
that well the big thing is is moving to
the screen junkies channel and it's
gonna be a day after the honest trailer
because we want to be able to see what
you think about it yes and include that
in the comments we actually really
enjoyed the MCU one where we were able
to as they say clap back at the haters
we get to see we had about 12 to 24
hours to for you to get your comments in
on the honest trailer itself and then
Wednesday morning we'll be on screen
junkies and we'll do this show but also
be able to respond to like what the
audience has thought about it and all
the things we miss every week thank you
so much for reminding us constantly of
all of our failures more beautiful
moments like the time that you were very
angry that the prequel to world war ii
joke didn't land here to talk about is
wild wild west i think last week was the
week before we did Waterworld and it was
like you know that's actually got some
fun redeeming qualities this movie not
so much you know this sucked as a bad I
know Billy business our own Billy
businesslike said I wish he was here to
defend it somehow but I can't imagine
what he would bring up no III do enters
I know what he would because they hate
something that as I've as I was watching
it he would be like how do you not find
that funny
he thinks that the bond going on the
boobie scene and the subsequent trying
to hang Will Smith scene is the funniest
thing he said okay well then again let's
take this into another video or maybe
just the office because this is not a
fun or funny movie this is a dark
twisted perverted take on what I assume
was like a fun old timey TV show people
who see who have watched it are huge
fans of the original wild wild west yeah
it's like maverick it's like James Bond
and the war in the Old West
yeah referencing Mel Gibson's maverick
yes people like oh that was a TV show
yes it was I didn't know that television
show James Garner is playing his
character from maverick in the movie
memory that's the twist as you think
it's a remake but it's actually a
continuation of that TV show maverick
that twist is just as dumb as this
movies twist to where it's AMA hags
husband was actually her father or the
other way around so it didn't make sense
I let her I love that when she reveals
that Will Smith is basically commenting
on the script and he's like could've
said back any point we're in fine we
would have helped but then we wouldn't
have gotten to see her but right yeah
right having a husband or a dad either
way the butt flap of those PJs could
comically fault what else
Will Smith sit in the movie he tries it
first
I feel like gives up if you chart his
accent he stops trying about halfway
through yeah yeah there's not much for
him to do I think that this is one of
those ones where they were depending on
him to like put some Will Smith on it to
make a lot of these jokes funny and
after a while he was like or you guys
could just write me jokes I'm just gonna
say the things that are gonna scream
this movies the clear delineation line
between fun Will Smith and movie actor
Will Smith
I feel like wild wild west in many ways
killed fun Will Smith forever Wow it's
been movie actor Will Smith okay not bad
I like movie actor Will Smith sometimes
Smith yeah yeah well he's running back
to the the open arms of the bad boys
franchise cuz he's spending too much
time in serious actor Island yeah
Aladdin was fun Will Smith by the way I
thought yeah I thought 11 was fun Will
Smith yeah fun Will Smith though he's I
mean there's it slapstick and it's
really camp positions dying slowly on
the inside yeah he's but I think he's
trying to be like a like more of an edge
like have more be more of a badass in
this movie and the movie is just not
there to serve that you know you don't
think that that cowboy costume is
harness I love a good vest naval
combination just like was cool in the
90s wrestlers were wearing fanny packs
t-shirts tucked into their jeans and
Will Smith was wearing a vest with no
shirt I felt bad for him all over again
cuz I probably haven't seen it since
twenty years ago when this movie came
out but it reminds me of watching men in
black International this year where it's
like anytime I see a very charismatic
actor trying as hard as they can
but being failed by every other aspect
of the movie it's very sad yeah cuz he's
Kevin Kline Will Smith they're doing
their best yeah they're tryin Will Smith
learn to ride a horse he learned all
those weird gun tricks he really tried
for this movie yes this movie failed
everyone it failed
Will Smith fans and failed fans of
westerns this is one of the only movie
steampunk enthusiasts get to hang on to
yeah yeah I'm the disabled yeah
the history of race in America women
obviously should have fans of the
Confederacy people like train trains not
John Peters because spider this movie is
like a make-a-wish for chumpy it's like
he probably said to someone he was gonna
die so they better put the giant spider
in this myth now and ever they are never
this is what we get
let's watch it shall we they're
surprisingly very little to say about it
except it sucks but you can even that
over his clothes five minutes of comedy
out of it this was a big reason why we
did blockbuster summer yeah what's the
meanest movie hey so we're getting
honest about summer blockbusters past
and present this is honest trailers
blockbusters summer from a director at
the height of his powers the biggest
movie star on the planet
and an untapped source material with an
original premise comes a cinematic
faceplant into a steaming pile of
worship
Will Smith passed on the matrix for this
you guys sorry
pause so there's a great video of Will
Smith just talking to camera about his
reasons for passing on the matrix and
it's great and it like kind of makes
sense at the time
in retrospect though you should have
done that one instead but he talks about
the Wachowski is coming to him and being
like so dude you're gonna like be in a
computer and you're gonna jump and kick
someone but like we're gonna see the
whole jump before you kick somebody and
he's like okay I could go work with this
guy that I made men in black yeah it's
like wild wild west men in black and it
was going to be Will Smith with Val
Kilmer he couldn't have two black people
in a movie it was gonna be Val Kilmer
was going to be the just a Laurence
Fishburne stepping on an American hands
about comer being like shares like never
what a bit beautiful yes Wow yeah weird
alternate history what could have been
yeah yeah that's in the last action hero
version of something now would Keanu
have been Will Smith and Wild Wild West
because that might have made it and what
would the matrix rap have been Smith
John Smith
call me Nia no Anderson sorry Wicky
Wicky wild wild west great opening
connection great game for the best movie
where a former runaway slave turned
cowboy teams up with an upper-crust
white guy so many big pops out of a
sleeve as they face off against a
flamboyant wealthy racist southern
villain okay second best so buzz this
story I think this started as it was
like a game of the second improv game
where like I said I think I first said
like this movie's a lot like jingo
Unchained and then everyone took their
turns going around the room turning in
their chairs and going this was a lot
like this - also a lot like this one
specific ways you can generalize
anything to be like oh well it's a buddy
cup Old West movie like yeah there's 15
of those that fit the bill when you
start getting into as we'll see shortly
like yeah that their home base is a
mechanical train and there it came out
July 4th weekend and like the yeah yeah
similarities kept piling up and the fun
writers room thing I think was we had
you had the Django point but we were
like trying to wrestle with is that a
run mm-hmm like can it be its own run or
is it just a quick starring gag but then
as those all started to come I became a
runner for the whole trailer yeah so
many things I think we left a few out -
so write us your own if you can think of
any yeah but keep going
okay second best but what's easily the
best sci-fi comedy of the 90s about a
mad scientist in the Old West whose base
camp is a hi-tech train
forgot about that one okay well it's
definitely the best barry sonnenfeld
directed sci-fi comedy buddy movie
[Laughter]
you're paying these guys to stand very
still at least put like four of them oil
paintings all the time there had to be
rehearsals for them just think this
audition yeah like how many guys did
they go through before it was like these
are the guys that can stand still in the
painting I'm assuming they have to go
through makeup every morning because
they all look oil painting a flat just
in case well you're also what Jim West
can't look at the painting from there
because otherwise the the jig is up yeah
so that's the other thing is it's it's a
risky gamble yeah also why do i do net
painting i want to see the side movie
about this home security salesman that's
sold loveless yeah that system a smurf
in like not Nantucket it's a it's in the
in Southern California they do what's
called the pageant of the Masters on
Gilmore Girls once well there you go
people trained all year to look like an
oil painting and it's like a whole thing
where people are doing makeup and for
multiple angles and stuff like that also
they could have just gods like a curtain
bring a bring Will Smith into this room
I'll hide behind the door and shoot
like it looks kind of cool but it's such
a throwaway thing it said like one wide
shot in the background you can actually
press it it's like at least feature it
if your gas you would feature it yeah
right
wasn't that a running gag in some movie
recently where it was like the best part
of the moot it wasn't spy no it was um
yeah you're right it was a Rob Riggle
Rob Riggle and he was camouflaged and he
kept stepping out of things oh my god
and you're right every time it was funny
Rob Riggle camouflage stepping out in an
otherwise unfunny film it's also not an
art theme developing new chemical arms
had come out of the desk and go ah yeah
really bothered me I can't wait for the
comments I'm gonna look it up forward ok
keep God out on July 4th weekend come on
meet Jim West and Artemus Gordon the
serious straight shooter and the wacky
sidekick but they never settle on which
one is which will sir myths shines as a
guy in the Cabinet Center outfit who
gives up on his exit halfway through the
movie and it'd be an awful career
decision darling we'd be getting that
life fast if you weren't dragging that
thing around and Kevin Klein shines as
the guy standing next to Will Smith yep
there is there is again Kevin you are
nailing this they'll team up to take
down the evil dr. loveless a racist
applause I think we kind of glossed
how's that but we were saying that one
of them needs to be the Tommy Lee Jones
yeah this duo one of them needs to be
the K to the J and I think neither of
them fully committed to being either J
or K this one yeah they were clearly
wank kevin kline zanuck tour yes they
were trying to give him things to do
with all of like the crazy characters
and because it's enough for him to just
be the inventor why does he also have to
dress up and be in drag so that he can
play the president yes like there's it's
just to give Kevin Kline stuff that's
right he just the inventor but they're
like okay so you're also horny
oh that's something we didn't ask this
question I thought you had the movie I
do is it done with number two yes
somewhat number - yes
so we got that problem solved a new
question is he a virgin
yes he doesn't know Karelin forty
everybody just not know what boobs feel
thank you
I said which was gonna be like did Steve
Karl's character from that movie write
this with the bags of the salmon Klein
is a his friends from that movie right
then yeah yeah yeah I I think that it's
Artemis may have been a virgin I think
so I think you're right I think you I'm
not casting aspersions it's just it's
just it's just a spot in the movie yeah
it's a perfectly fine choice or not
choice but he is he is not only is he
like I don't think he's even seen you
know like a daguerreotype of its body
he's never seen like a sketch of what is
you know the 18 something's and like an
ankle you know would have you changing
your chaps you know back then get a
glimpse of that sweet sweet
[Laughter]
you could almost cut out Will Smith and
this is like a Leslie Nielsen spy movie
where he's just like in a weird
Inspector Gadget yeah yeah Sufi Magoo
character yep yeah it stinks keep going
Thanks there's a bad note racist fascist
mad scientist trying to overthrow the
government but that won't stop our
heroes from really pausing come back
Matt for a second yes if you are gonna
carve up America
yeah why would you give yourself I'm
sorry no offense the Pacific Northwest
Wyoming in the badlands it's your plan
you can take the pick of the litter of
all the comment of United States a blank
if your whole thing is you love big
mechanical spiders you're probably not
gonna want to be in one of the wettest
places where it could rain at any moment
yeah they rust alone yeah that thing's
gonna be under a tarp ten months out of
the year mm-hmm I will say that I think
the Pacific Northwest is actually the
steel of that US states draft it's the
rest of it that I mean I Minnesota it's
cold it's flat what's what are you what
are you doing man on the French the
French love Minnesota I think that was a
deal breaker there's one thing I know
about the French usually it's that
Minnesota is the crown jewel they would
be French Empire okay that's true well
then anyways that's what these gems keep
going
government but that won't stop our
heroes from really taking him to task
for being disabled well I can see where
it'd be difficult for a man of your
stature to keep in touch with even half
the people you know crazy beards out
your height see them actually I was
thinking about that stuff your little
half ass in one of these cannons and
fertilize the landscape with you that's
all you're gonna roast him for my fella
comes back from the dead I find that an
occasion to stand up we got a lot of
jail cells down 40 where do we luckily
your father or something I guess when it
comes right down to it you just can't
beat a good old-fashioned pair of leg
voices like is having of legs he's
slapping them the joke that he has legs
and the other guy lost them in a war a
misguided war mind you but they still a
war veteran wound it's not like you born
that way it's just a mess all the way
down mass it felt like a placeholder in
the sense of land looking to the yelling
too but like there's the scene with this
projection thing where like you they
wrote the line that is a man's head
script they were like okay for now we're
just gonna this is a placeholder because
he's gonna come up with some other funny
stuff to say but and then the cop I look
of the movie it just cuts back to Will
Smith it just says slower every time I'm
wondering again that's another one with
like what he'll put some will stank on
it yeah and he doesn't like he doesn't
even do a voice he just says it's slower
and it's because it's funny cuz it's
seeking it also again figure it out this
is a man who's again who cares but
because this movie's awful but like this
is a man who shoots people to death all
the time slave who's like wedged amongst
the Native Americans he's seen some
stuff killed a lot of people in his life
never a man's head no they had made hems
okay
case Tommy Lee Jones right yeah okay if
they had made him like the younger K
then President grants like you're gonna
go work with this crazy Inspector Gadget
guy and he's just completely
straight-laced him okay that I get weird
little interactions like that but like
yeah it's dudes head in a jar you're a
cowboy secret agent it's a Wild West
dumping you was like boiling up a wombat
or whatever that was
rough-and-tumble time young girl
spaceman somebody would have eaten that
head if you came down to it yeah this is
the most chaotic least comfortable time
in American history
I'm not saying it would be disturbing
but he's acting like never he didn't
grow up with a pampered lifestyle far
from it no now Artemis
I can see right if Will Smith brings in
a severed man's head and it's like that
is a minister yeah yeah but that's this
thing's we can't figure out who's who
no they don't know who's ooh mmm guys
this is a bad movie I think it's
ill-formed no curious wants to bring
back slavery gonna dig in for that at
all
you know beautiful women they encourage
your one-minute got the legs out from
under you even next help just the leg
jokes okay cool I'm just as tough as you
are to the invaders Oh Lady
impetuous I know that seems tacked on
but Sochi
he's so courageous oh so graceful return
to the time to confront the most
shameful issue of American history
boners because this movie is so horny
that when it's not showing you its horny
gadgets touch it's constantly trying to
show you its dick
lazy sex jokes
by the way boobies look great tonight
not so many she's a breast of fresh air
some square in my sight sire
[Music]
fresh ass this is why why yes he is
making goose noises dance he's doing
from what was dressed as a lady like is
that what Jim West thinks sexy is if
he's trying to distract loveless do you
think I was his demo reel for the genie
knew he could pull it off man yeah this
movie that was our big takeaway I think
all of us this table was how
unrepentantly horniness film oh yeah
yeah all the jokes are sex jokes yeah
but yeah or having no legs jack well cuz
so I the way that this worked was that
the first time they sent this to
audiences the feedback they got was that
they couldn't they didn't know it was a
comedy so then they had someone come in
and do another pass as what would I have
been referring to as the horny pass yeah
cuz my guess is they just added in a
bunch of sex jokes yeah cuz like maybe a
couple things were horny in there like
oh we'll just really lean into that ya
know it was a comedy yeah a producer's
like 14 year old son came in and I guess
if you cut out every joke if you cut out
all the horny jokes which is every joke
then it's just a really serious movie
about a guy who painted the same so I
could see audiences coming away from it
racists versus a guy gray kind of
antihero
I guess it kind of it's I imagine this
movie coming out today know about it I
mean it would just be instantly roasted
from you know every day every day yeah
but it wouldn't do well enough to really
be in part of people's consciousness for
more than a week well now this would
just come and go and be like wow that
was weird which I think it did I don't
think it'd be too different I mean but
it was like a huge thing I mean this was
a this is another minute black Pike
cultural event songs yes
yeah that's food tie-ins you can build
the build up this is the movie of the
summer I mean a pretty cool of music
video yes yeah the music video does have
extended footage that didn't make it
into the film it's actually a sequel
music sequel because summer hacks like
I've been having dreams about and then
he's back and kidnaps her from a room a
seductive den that was built for the two
of them with it maybe two hundred
candles it looks like the inside of like
Catholic Church devotional like it is
wall-to-wall candle and and actual
spiders pop out anyways gotta go only
Cisco Juho know Smith is doing a much
better job of acting he actually looks
like he's having fun yeah yes well it's
cuz the good name of Will Smith his
musical career is on the line
yeah plus this goes they're just having
fun they're Japs yeah
Dru Hill is in the background which by
the way because they hated having to be
in the background Francisco at least one
member of Dru Hill quit because of the
one of them I assume the guy who says
wild wild west no that is I believe it's
Koo Modi oh yeah okay it's like an older
rapper because I think a Wild West song
okay drew hills contribution that Cisco
Cisco is Dru Hill that was his original
band and then he became the breakout
star with Phong sauce 2000s have merged
that was the early Beyonce
yeah I've Dru Hill well the more you
know mm-hmm Cisco is such a shining star
I never even realized who's part of a
group see has only ever been Cisco to me
and that's why content the other channel
is gonna love so disappointed rest it's
only legacy it is five Razzies one great
Kevin Smith and a goat so anyway I'm
going to meet John Peters he's like I
got some directives for you he's got a
fight a giant spot watch the whole
resurgence of Keanu Reeves but hey at
least it's the best kevin kline movie
where he impersonates the president
really the best sci-fi and western with
an anachronistic theme song gotta be
kidding me the best movie where Will
Smith fights a redneck in an engine room
of a mechanical spider
I learned neck from a
no small parts no nailed it
starring hee ha
Shannon Internet inspect her gadgets
dental out of distress chitinous be a
spider-man villain DJ ear horn were
partying I study the plays and Will
Smith trying to make a line funnier by
yelling it
named Gordon
is that they shed him make volume funny
jokes work the not very good the bad and
the somehow even worse some hope
befitting that in town yeah barmy wishes
John Peters didn't get to force the
giant spider into this movie and had to
put it in one of his others like a star
is born it again actually deleted scenes
no net oh yes story will not eggs
I want to will with a big hat and some
smokey image okay dr. Emmett cloud climb
stop this crazy thing
Once Upon a Time in Mexico you'd prefer
to forget iron Vanek spider-ham Peter
les Parker the amazing spider-man far
from home II just movie fights you know
Will Smith was really ahead of the curve
on this one we lead so lil no sex could
halt yes he did yes so during movie
fights I'd already had that written and
during the fights when you said that I
turned a lot and I was like that's
actually in the starring that I just
yeah synchronicity beautiful thing when
I saw the script I didn't see that said
phonograph I thought it was photograph
and I thought it was about the guys and
the paintings on the wall oh man well
gosh have we said all there is to say
about wild wild west we have we could
talk more about the song I think we did
it's a good video you have to watch the
uncut one which i think is only on like
dailymotion or set the wrong
that's where those live now yeah the
extended cut is is only there um and
yeah this was a very regrettable moment
in Will Smith's career I think he
realized it I think we realize it but
I'm glad to happen because it would have
ruined the matrix much yes much like too
much like the movie wild wild west I
expected this to be much more fun yeah
if people are looking for remakes why
not remake things that didn't work like
this and try to try to make it happen
you know yeah remake this remake
Waterworld sign my petition theory on
how to fix Waterworld very correct
because I saw the stunt show for the
very first time this weekend and it's
the best yes right existing for that too
it yeah yeah it was so fun yeah so yeah
we're right yep you said in the splash
zone oh yeah I'm very splashed list even
the splash stunt show is even better
anyways for this week come back next
week on the screen junkies YouTube
channel on Wednesday where we will be
covering something that I mentioned
maybe 30 seconds ago the hot name yeah a
hot button issue hot button issue going
to kick off in front of a broader
audience
yes exactly perhaps we'll see we'll see
and we'll see you then bye bye
[Music]
you